a team is Charlie so Walking Dead just
released a brand new trailer for season
5 so this is gonna be a breakdown of
that and some mailbag I haven't done a
Q&A in a while and I want to do my
Michonne videos a separate thing so
that's still coming probably this Sunday
and more important stuff happening this
week so announcements at the end of the
video heads up to I'll be starting my
weekly Walking Dead giveaway soon so be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
we would love to have you on the team if
you like talking about Walking Dead
we'll be doing it every single week
it'll be a lot of fun okay so here we go
careful for spoilers for everything
through seasons four on Walking Dead
I'll wait just a sec okay here we go
starting off with the fire walkers
patrolling terminus it's hard to tell
just from this clip but most of the time
trailers like this like these really
short ones only include bits from the
first couple of episodes it just implies
that walkers are gonna get into terminus
somehow and I hope you do not have
epilepsy because this next montage is
totally gonna give you a seizure
it just tells more about the shitstorm
that goes down at terminus it's all
footage from the previous trailers but I
think the Garrett's voiceover is a clue
it's not over until we're all dead I
think the montage just tells the story
of the destruction of terminus at some
point Rick and the survivors barrel out
of the Train cart just like we saw in
the first trailer then get their hands
on some guns and manage to blow a giant
chunk out of terminus and let's have
walkers in Carroll also shows up later
to the trailer so I feel like she's a
part of that too somehow and even after
all that it's not the end Gareth is seen
with them in the trailer and later seen
so he's travelling with them for some
reason possibly because of Eugene's cure
which may or may not be faked
if you have read the comics just use
spoiler tags when you're talking about
it in the comments they released some
images of Carol and Tyreese outside of
terminus with Judith so at some point
they arrived at terminus before
everything goes crazy and here we see
Carol asking about the people holding
this giant rifle that just looks like
it's a terminus at night so she seems
like a big part of their escape plan or
if she just outright rescues them
herself I would be surprised if all
these scenes are only from the first
episode but it's totally possible this
big explosion and these fire Walker's
happen at the climax it would be a
pretty badass way to open the season and
this season
has been teased as like a return to the
crazy action of season 3 these Rick's
beaches here inside this church there's
been a couple different scenes where
he's talking to Carl and the other
people about not trusting people until
we meet a new group I'm gonna assume
he's either talking about the people
from terminus or he's talking about
Abraham Eugene Rosita and Tara like all
the new people that join them I'm also
thinking this church is father Gabriel's
we've seen it from the outside at night
it doesn't seem like it's near terminus
it seems like it's somewhere out in the
woods somewhere so in addition to all
this new footage there was a new
synopsis that was posted to Fox
internationals website so I'll read it
season 5 is a story that weaves the true
motives of the people of terminus with
the hopeful prospect of a cure in
Washington DC the fate of the group's
lost comrades as well as new locales new
conflicts and new obstacles and keeping
the group together and staying alive
stories will break apart and intersect
the characters will find love and hate
peace and Conflict contentment and
terror and in the quest to find a
permanent safe place to call home one
question will haunt them after all
they've seen all they've done all
they've sacrificed lost and held onto no
matter to the costs who do they become
so a big question what the hell is all
that's supposed to mean I think we've
all come to the conclusion that the
terminus people are just analogs of the
hunters from the comics so that's what I
think the true motives line is all about
Washington DC of course is one of the
next big locations in the story they
aren't anywhere close to that terminus
is in Macon Georgia so clearly it's
gonna take a while for them to get there
at some point in the first couple of
episodes they're gonna have to hit the
road to head in that direction no idea
if they'll get there before season 6
they really didn't travel that far from
the prison in season 4 the line about
lost comrades sounds like Beth we know
her story's gonna take place away from
the survivors at this weird creepy
Hospital for at least half the season
new locales could include father
Gabriel's church here no idea when Seth
Gilliam is gonna show up in the story
the new obstacles [ __ ] just sounds like
them running into crazies on the way to
Washington DC like obviously there's
going to be some big locations on the
road when they talk about stories
breaking apart in intersecting I'm
wondering if some of them might split up
after they escaped terminus like Abraham
and a group will head to Washington DC
and a couple of others will go in a
different direction to try and find Beth
or it's possible the story's splitting
apart could just be about Beth having
stories of her own like episodes of her
own like the governor got his own
episodes I will say that one of my
favorite things about this new trailer
is Carol here in full poncho gear and
warpaint
you should note that whenever you wear
that poncho you get a 60% bonus to your
crit rating so [ __ ] is gonna go down so
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the trailer what are you looking
forward to most do you think that Carol
is gonna save everyone so while you guys
think about all that here is some
mailbag question number one
Muhammad asks when does season 5 start
that is a good question
for people in the US and people that
stream their television it starts
October 12th if you're watching on TV in
the UK or internationally I think
there's a couple week delay for the
episodes airing like you get episodes a
couple of week after we get episodes
anybody from the UK that's watching this
please confirm in the comments question
number two
Jason Panetta asks do you think that
someone from the group will die in
terminus no but I do think that one of
the lesser characters will die this
season like on the way to Washington DC
I basically I don't think everyone is
gonna make it to Washington DC question
number three Nicko mark asks could the
building that Beth is in be connected to
terminus is it nearby I actually think
it's somewhere completely different we
don't know where it is right now I feel
like her story is gonna be apart from
the survivors until at least the second
half of season five question number four
bhoomesh asks do you think they showed
too much footage in the trailer I would
say every trailer for everything
anywhere ever spoils everything about
the plot I know it sounds a little silly
but all trailers spoil everything
there's really no way around it I spend
most of my time trying to analyze
episodes of TV and movies and things for
discussion so my enjoyment nowadays
really doesn't depend so much on big
twists in the plot like I don't get
really excited about things that could
be spoilery I mostly just get excited
for actors being amazing in scenes like
melting my face off with crazy
monologues or just being amazing I do
try to be careful about the way I
presents
boilers because not everyone reads the
comic but it exists so potentially you
could read what's going on in the story
way way ahead of what's going on in the
show even though technically the show is
supposed to be a little bit different
it's the same deal with Game of Thrones
and last one question number five lucy
asks how do you think that Rick will
react to Tara I think he's just be wary
of any new person like he's not gonna
trust any new people this season that
includes Abraham Eugene Rosita obviously
Gareth creepy terminus guy I mean
generally Rick is not gonna be that
friendly this season he's in like
hunter-killer mode okay so a couple
quick announcements I'll be posting that
me showing video on Sunday that'll be my
next countdown video but tonight is
agents of shield season 2 I'll be
posting my review after the episode but
I already did a really big preview video
so you can click here to watch that it's
gonna be fun season Lucy Lawless is
gonna be I'm just gonna kick a lot of
butt and you can click here for my top 5
badass Rick Grimes moments alright so
thanks for watching everybody let's high
five and we'll meet back up for shield
tonight